[Musik]
umstrittener durchbruch in thüringen
bodo ramelow einigt sich mit der union
und kann mit seiner wiederwahl zum
ministerpräsidenten rechnen
die bundes cdu reagiert empört
solidarität statt spaltung nach dem
anschlag von hanau demonstrieren
tausende gegen rassismus und hetze wm
silber nach aufholjagd trotz fehlstarts
stürmt die deutsche frauen staffel in
antholz noch auf rang zwei
[Applaus]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
den nachrichten am samstag mit
ausgiebigem sport und norbert lehmann am
tor von mir
erst sah es so aus als hätten die
thüringische cdu und rot-rot-grünen
erfurt gestern abend eine lösung für die
regierungskrise gefunden
doch das sieht die cdu im bund heute
ganz anders
dazu gleich mehr zuerst zum kompromiss
in thüringen vier christdemokraten so
die idee sollten nun doch den linken
ramelow zu ministerpräsidenten mit
wählen damit der ohne stimmen aus der
afc eine stabile übergangsregierung
bilden kann
melanie haack heute morgen in erfurt
sitzt die basis zusammen der cdu
ortsverband hochheim beim mitglieder
frühstück am tag nach dem nächsten
tabubruch im thüringer landtag die
meisten sind sauer
es kommt genau so wie es eigentlich
nicht kommen sollte denn die wähler
haben am 27 oktober gewählt und die
haben rot-rot-grün abgewählt und mit
diesem verhandlungsergebnis wird ein
ministerpräsident ramelow wahrscheinlich
wieder in sein amt kommen der aber
gerade in dieser konstellation nicht das
vertrauen der wähler bekommen hat und am
abend hatten rot rot grün und die cdu
sich mühsam geeinigt bodo ramelow als
ministerpräsident einer
minderheitsregierung nächstes jahr im
april neuwahl der fahrplan eigentlich
klar
doch heute nachmittag schien er mit dem
tweet der cdu thüringen wieder zu
wackeln
die cdu fraktion im thüringer landtag
werde bodo ramelow nicht aktiv weiß
ministerpräsidenten mitwählen
die linke geht trotzdem davon aus dass
bodo ramelow am vierten märz gewählt
wird gehen davon aus dass wir das
gemeinsam in thüringen so machen wir es
gestern geschrieben haben
wenn bodo ramelow nicht gewählte wird
oder nicht klar ist das ist nur
demokratie bestimmt worden sprich die
afg hätte ihn mit gewählt dann wird
boeing nun dass man sagt ja nicht an dem
aus der cdu fraktion selbst heute kein
statement nur so viel man akzeptiere
mehrheitlich das verhandlungsergebnis
von freitagabend
während spd grüne und linke in berlin
den kompromiss in thüringen als
lösungsvorschlag gutheißen fallen die
reaktionen der bundes cdu zu den
beschlossenen erfurt hasch und total
ablehnend aus von historischer dummheit
ist gar die rede
heike slansky eine politische
kampfansage aus den eigenen reihen muss
er heute abwehren der cdu
generalsekretär bleibt auf linie und
ward seine parteifreunde aus thüringen
wer herrn ramelow als kandidatin der
linken zum ministerpräsidenten wählt
verstößt gegen die beschlüsse der cdu es
geht hier um nicht weniger als um die
glaubwürdigkeit der cdu deutschlands
insgesamt es geht hier um
grundüberzeugung und um grundwerte und
nicht um politische spielchen die cdu in
aufruhr jens spahn einer der aspiranten
auf den parteivorsitz twittert die union
befinde sich in einer vertrauenskrise
es gehe jetzt um die substanz der partei
nicht nur in thüringen eine historische
dummheit meint kai wegner chef des
berliner cdu landesverbandes einen
tabubruch korrigiert man nicht durch
einen weiteren klare haltung fordert
bernd althusmann chef der cdu
niedersachsen die wahl ramalhos sei
schleichendes gift für die cdu
schadenfreude bei afg und linken
die cdu ist sozusagen völlig entkernt
hat überhaupt keine überzeugung mehr und
hofft darauf dass vielleicht in einem
jahr die leute nicht mehr so streng sind
die cdu hat ja jahrzehnte lang agiert
nach der hufeisen theorie wonach sie
sich gleichermaßen gegen links und
rechts abgrenzt
diese hufeisen theorie ist nun erledigt
dieser abschied war wirklich längst
überfällig die thüringer cdu schert sich
offenbar nicht um bundes beschlüsse der
berliner parteizentrale läuft etwas aus
dem ruder
ausgang offen ein ziemliches dilemma für
die cdu oder theo koll
das kann man wohl sagen und das dilemma
wird immer größer die zäune werden immer
höher gezogen die gewählten vokabeln die
wir eben gehört haben beschreiben ja das
ausmaß der krise da ist von gift die
rede und von beschädigung
der glaubwürdigkeit der gesamten cdu mir
gegenüber hat heute jemand aus der
bundes cdu von einer geiselhaft
gesprochenen die thüringen die cdu nehme
das heute sofort alle generalsekretäre
getagt haben ist auch ein symbol für die
größe dieser krise am ende stehen zwei
grundwerte gegeneinander die freiheit
der cdu abgeordneten gegen den cdu
parteitagsbeschluss zusammengenommen
ergibt es ein riesen dilemma und eines
das zu bleiben scheint vielen dank für
die einordnung theo koll in berlin
die regierungskrise in thüringen alle
facetten und wollten und der massive
gegenwind von seiten der bundes-cdu
natürlich auch bei uns im internet auf
heute.de gewählt wird morgen ganz
regulär in hamburg die parteien haben
heute ein letztes mal um stimmen mehr
als 1,3 millionen menschen sind
aufgerufen eine neue bürgerschaft zu
wählen klarer favorit ist bürgermeister
peter tschentscher seine spd liegt in
umfragen deutlich vor den grünen von
katharina fegebank beide wollen ihre rot
grüne regierung in hamburg fortsetzen
von dort berichtet ralf zimmermann von
sievert sie wollte es eigentlich werden
doch so wie es aussieht wird er es wohl
bleiben
das kopf-an-kopf-rennen von rot und grün
ist abgesagt dementsprechend gelassen
zeigte sich hamburgs erster
bürgermeister peter tschentscher heute
bei seinen letzten wahlkampfterminen
unsere botschaft ist die ganze stadt im
blick zu haben
diese solidarische stadtgesellschaft in
den blick zu nehmen ist etwas was den
menschen wichtig ist gerade wenn man so
in anderen ländern sieht wie ausgrenzend
und und zunehmend auch feindlich in der
politik miteinander umgegangen wird
die grüne spitzenkandidatin katharina
fegebank wird nun wohl weiter regieren
müssen unter führung der spd wenn auch
mit deutlich größerem akzent
ich hätte gerne andere vorzeichen gehabt
nämlich grün-rot tatsächlich wir haben
in den letzten jahren gut
zusammengearbeitet
der wahlkampf hat sicherlich die ein
oder andere spur hinterlassen
die oppositionelle cdu muss morgen ihr
historisch womöglich schlechtestes
ergebnis in der hansestadt verkraften
wir müssen ernsthaft annehmen dass in
großstädten wie im innerstädtischen
bereich im urbanen milieu wie man
soziologisch sagt dass wir da in weiten
teilen den anschluss verlieren oder
schon verloren haben und das wird eine
aufgabe sondern auch für den oder die
neue parteivorsitzende für die
elbliberalen wird es mit der
fünf-prozent-hürde wohl eine knappe
angelegenheit auch dank der
parteifreunde und deren verhalten in
thüringen das passieren fehler
und das sind schwerwiegender fehler
gewesen und dafür muss man sich
entschuldigen das ist ja nun auch
passiert aber dennoch sollte man das
nicht instrumentalisieren weil dann
freuen sich die renner in diesem fall
insbesondere die fdp gegen die hatten
nach den morden in hanau tausende gleich
am donnerstag demonstriert dennoch sehen
auch die hamburger rechtspopulisten sich
in keinerlei verantwortung dass sondern
an zusammenhang konstruiert wird
zwischen der politik der afd
und diesen rechtsextremistischen
straftaten und da sind wir natürlich
auch gefordert zu belegen und deutlich
zu machen dass die afd damit nun so gut
wie gar nichts zu tun hat die hamburger
linke definiert sich schon vor der wahl
weiter als oppositionspartei die
botschaft des übergroßen kreuzes auf dem
hamburger rathausmarkt übrigens lautet
ein deutliches demokratisches signal zu
setzen morgen mit einer hohen
wahlbeteiligung
bettina schausten zdf wahlstudio in
hamburg die spd liegt also vorn ganz
gegen den trend welches signalwörter
setzen also nun in der tat kann sich die
spd nach vielen niederlagen mal wieder
auf einen erfreulichen wahlabend
einstellen aber ein erfolg für peter
tschentscher wäre tatsächlich seien und
keiner mit dem sich die bundes partei
wirklich schmücken könnte rot-grün davon
gehen wir hier aus wird bestätigt mit
deutlich stärkeren grünen aber der
wechsel auf grün an der spitze der ist
den hamburgern dann offenbar doch zu
viel eher und unabhängig davon wird
morgen von interesse sein ob und wie
sich die aktuellen ereignisse jenseits
von hamburg auswirken die in thüringen
zumal die cdu ist das haben wir gerade
ja gesehen weiterhin den schwärmen
fahrwasser auch die fdp muss mit folgen
rechnen könnte sogar aus der
bürgerschaft heraus fallen ob der
mordanschlag von hanau das afg ergebnis
beeinflusst auch das ist möglich vor
fünf jahren begann hier in hamburg eine
serie ständiger wahlerfolge für die afg
ist könnte morgen für sie erstmals
wieder abwärts gehen
wir melden uns hier aus dem zdf
wahlstudio in hamburg ab 17.45 bis dahin
vielen dank für den ausblick bettina bis
morgen dann aktionspläne gegen rechts
oder verschärfungen des waffenrechts
nach dem anschlag von hanau wird über
mögliche konsequenzen diskutiert so
erwägt innenminister seehofer etwa
psychologische tests für waffenbesitzer
sollte es auffälligkeiten geben
in hanau ging heute mehrere tausend
menschen gegen rechte gewalt und
intoleranz auf die straße isabel de la
vega nationalismus raus aus den köpfen
hanau belang zeichen setzen
kurdische gruppen
gewerkschaftsmitglieder antirassismus
initiativen und die angehörigen der
opfer des attentats wir haben hier
kinder verloren brüder verloren mutter
verloren der vater verloren sind alles
kinder von hanno die sind hier geboren
hier aufgewachsen
deutschlands genau das ist das thema das
die stadt jetzt bewegt wie konnte so ein
verbrechen passieren woher der hass ist
multikulti doch gescheitert haben
gedacht dass das ganz gut funktioniert
hat bisher
und jetzt ist das passiert wir sind
völlig geschockt total geschockt in
hanau hat die hälfte der bewohner einen
migrationshintergrund das attentat
schürt die sorge zum beispiel vor
racheakten
es könnte sein dass man sich dann
irgendwie arrangiert oder soja wir sind
mehr und wir halten zusammen das aber
ist die hoffnung der meisten hier auf
dem marktplatz hoffe einfach nur dass
alle zusammen rücken mehr und mehr
zusammenhalten und sich nicht von einem
der der wie man so schön sagt bisschen
geistig gestört auch war das von einem
sich beeinflussen lassen
die demonstranten ziehen später auch an
einem der beiden tatorte vorbei
das verbrechen wird hanau noch lange
beschäftigen sorge in italien dort sind
erstmals zwei europäer nach einer
infektion mit dem chor ohne virus
gestorben eine 77 jährige frau und ein
78 jähriger mann in berlin landete am
morgen eine maschine mit sechs deutschen
sie hatten zwei wochen in quarantäne an
bord eines kreuzfahrtschiffs in japan
verbracht bei ihnen ist das virus
bislang nicht nachgewiesen worden
jetzt sollen sie zwei weitere wochen zu
hause isoliert werden
nach frankreich genauer nach fessenheim
dort im ältesten atomkraftwerk des
landes wurde in der nacht der erste von
zwei reaktoren abgeschaltet
der zweite block soll am 30 juni vom
netz genommen werden
nach der kompletten abschaltung des 43
jahre alten meilers hat frankreich noch
18 atomkraftwerke die rund 70 prozent
des stroms liefern das ist mit abstand
der höchste anteil weltweit das aus für
fessenheim ist in frankreich umstritten
christel hass
fessenheim das opfer steht auf dem
plakat das am zaun des akw-geländes
hängt die die sich hier versammelt haben
sind wütend und traurig die entscheidung
das atomkraftwerk endgültig stillzulegen
ist für sie ein großer fehler
wir verstehen das nicht es gibt weder
sicherheit noch umweltrisiken und auch
keine wirtschaftlichen probleme
trotzdem müssen wir den standort
aufgeben jura die sonko es wird weniger
arbeitsplätze geben viele müssen ihre
häuser verkaufen und noch mehr werden
weg gehen müssen
auch der bürgermeister ist gekommen er
hat lange für den erhalt des akw
gekämpft
wir leben sehr gut und sehr sicher mit
dem akw und man darf nicht vergessen die
atomindustrie ist eine saubere industrie
fessenheim ist das älteste atomkraftwerk
frankreichs es liegt direkt an der
grenze zu deutschland und wird dort als
risiko reaktor eingeschätzt mit der
abschaltung beugt sich paris dem druck
des nachbarlands und auch die
französischen kernkraft gegner sind
zufrieden
das ist eine gute nachricht für die
sicherheit der anwohner und für die
französische wirtschaft weil wir endlich
den fokus auf die erneuerbaren energien
richten können
was bleibt ist die frage wie nach dem
aus des kernkraftwerks neue
arbeitsplätze in fessenheim geschaffen
werden können
geplant ist ein deutsch-französisches
industriezentrum doch konkretes gibt es
noch nicht und nun studieren zum sport
und zum erfolg der deutschen biathleten
bei der wm in antalya fangen wir mit der
männerstaffel an die hat bronze geholt
ein treppchen höher auf dem siegerpodest
schafften es die frauen über 4 x 6
kilometer silber nach schwachem start
und starker aufholjagd als denise
herrmann ins ziel kommt es die freude
bei den deutschen damen über silber auch
deshalb so groß weil zwischendurch kaum
noch einer damit rechnen konnte
[Applaus]
franziska preuß das deutsche quartett
das nach dem ersten wechsel von heuchler
auf hin zur fr 19 zurückgefallen war
durch eine perfekte stehen vorstellung
auf rang zwei schlussläuferin hermann
verlor den zweiten platz oder kämpften
hinter norwegen und vor der ukraine
zurück
es ist die insgesamt vierte
silbermedaillen für deutschland hier in
antholz
bei strahlendem sonnenschein wechselten
die männer auf gold kurs liegen zum
letzten mal doch schlussläufer benedikt
dollar bestellen rabenschwarzen tag
musste stehend in die strafrunde
gold und silber gingen nach frankreich
und norwegen deutschland mit lisa horn
und bauer freute sich verhalten über
bronze vor dem wettkampf in antholz
wurde sprint weltmeister alexander login
auf aus russland von der italienischen
polizei verhört außerdem wurde sein
hotelzimmer durchsucht und material
beschlagnahmt
kino war bereits wegen dopings für zwei
jahre gesperrt worden
bei der bob wm in altenberg führt
olympiasieger francesco friedrich nach
zwei von vier läufen ganz souverän und
steuert einem historischen sieg entgegen
dem sechsten zweier titel in folge ja
und bei den deutschen frauen da gab es
eine überraschende silbermedaille khimki
rechts und ihre anschieberin kiraly
parade das überraschungsteam der wm in
altenberg als zwei weltcuprennen hat die
junioren weltmeisterin aus wiesbaden
bislang absolviert nun hielten ihre
nerven auch am zweiten tag wm silber
können sie das schon so realisiert ich
glaube nicht um ehrlich zu sein als ist
mega aber ich glaube ich kann das kommt
wahrscheinlich erst heute abend heute
nacht irgendwann nur superstar kelly
humphries aus den usa war noch etwas
schneller dritte die kanadierin debüt in
der fußball bundesliga hat sich der bvb
für die dfb pokal pleite in bremen
revanchiert und es durch den sieg gegen
werder auf platz zwei der tabelle
geklettert
die bisherigen ergebnisse des 23
spieltags bremen unterliegt dortmund mit
nur zu zwei gladbach und hoffenheim
trennen sich unentschieden eins zu eins
hertha verliert haushoch gegen köln 0 2
5-heimpleite auch für freiburg 0 2 gegen
düsseldorf das abendspiel schalke gegen
leipzig bereits gestern besiegten die
bayern paderborn mit 3 zu 2 morgen noch
leverkusen augsburg und wolfsburg mainz
und am montag frankfurt gegen union
berlin
ja die tabelle die bayern weiterhin
erster vier punkte vor dortmund und
leipzig
rb kann aber den zweiten platz heute
abend zurück erobern
gladbach bleibt vierter leverkusen
fünfter schalke sechster die zweite
tabellenhälfte beginnt mit frankfurt ja
hinten alles unverändert düsseldorf
bremen und paderborn als tabellenletzter
ja und schalke gegen leipzig ausführlich
später bei uns im aktuellen sportstudio
heute 23 30 zu gast viktoria rebensburg
die skirennläuferin danken
das nächste sturmtief nähert sich und
bringt viel regen mehr dazu gleich beim
wetter von özden terli so viel von uns
an diesem samstag danke für ihr
interesse
marietta slomka erwartet sie um 23 uhr
15 zu einem späten heute-journal und
morgen freut sich an dieser stelle hier
barbara hahlweg auf sie schönen abend
noch
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ein sturmtief jagt
das andere und hier kommt schon
sturmtief julia angerauscht und einmal
über deutschland hinweg und so gibt es
schon in der kommenden nacht regen
verbreitet über der mitte und bis nach
norden an der nordsee teilweise
sturmböen um west die temperaturen
sinken dabei auf vier grad an den küsten
und 10 grad im rhein-main-gebiet morgen
ist eine menge los sturmböen orkanartige
böen aus westlichen richtungen
also hier im strafbereich sehr sehr
windig seien sie auf der hut ansonsten
viel regen teilweise 30 bis 40 in
staulagen bis zu 50 liter auf den
quadratmeter temperaturen dazu
erreichten maximalwerte von 6 grad im
norden sonst 14 bis 16 teils 18 grad im
südosten deutschlands am rosenmontag im
westen viele wolken und regen bis 13
grad im südwesten milder um 18 grad
ja und am aschermittwoch ist auch das
milde wetter vorbei
die temperaturen steigen nur noch für
ein bis sechs grad dazu haben wir es mit
schauern und gewittern zu tun damit ein
schöner abend